all right I've got some other calls are
popped in and I want to hear some of
them man I haven't heard any of them
let's go hey what's up deal this is John
I'm calling right now from middle of
nowhere Louisiana oh man well thanks for
cup thanks for calling man pick up a
hitchhiker dude take your chances you
know what I'm saying
pick up a hitchhiker bro roadside
roulette I'm on a road trip right now
from Jacksonville Florida to Dallas
Texas just headed back to school and
driving through the back roads of
Louisiana made me think of a question
for you what kind of stuff did you guys
do growing up in high school for fun
like there was this kid on American Idol
I don't know if you seen him if you
haven't you should check them out he's
awesome
Naima Layne Hardy he's from Louisiana
and when we Bryan asked what kind of
stuff he did for fun he said I'd just
like to drive my truck around and then
Katy Perry asked Oh what are you doing
driving truck burnings at all I just
like to burn gas so I just want to ask
well if that's the kind of stuff you
guys been driving your truck driver and
gas let me think about that that's a
good question what do we do I think you
know I mean we did drugs I remember at
some point we did some good drugs and
bad drugs too you know I grew up in the
bad Ellis and the bad acid belt and a
lot of bad acid would come through our
area the armored one time we got real
high on some acid and um cooked up pizza
and a dryer and it took about four
cycles to do um on permanent press to do
a medium and it comes out as a calzone
you put it in as a pizza and it comes
out more as like a calzone or just like
a hot kind of ball of Italian what else
did we do that's a good question what
did I do
well I used to walk a lot you know
because I didn't there was something
weird before I got a car I didn't want
to be seen there's an age where you
don't want to be seen on a bicycle like
a bicycles too much for children so but
you know and you don't have a
are you so you walk so I will walk a lot
you know so I walk five six miles to get
somewhere to do something you know good
at arcade or something and what else did
we do ride around you know I used to I
used to get a bicycle and I get a
bicycle I was mean steal one out of
somebody's yard and sometime it could be
anybody's bicycle I take that sucker and
I bike over to my girl's house I had
this little you know beautiful white
girl I was seeing that she was you know
there you know that rubenesque a little
bad girl you know and we go over there
and I sneak up in her room and it had a
cat
they had this grey cat I had to sneak
past this little [ __ ] bra and he
was always trying to start something
with me you know like he like we had met
in a previous life and I'd done
something wrong to him you know like
maybe like a couple hundred years ago
he'd been you know was eating a piece of
fish or something by a river and I came
up and stole that carp out of his hand
and so you know now he's out here he's
trying to get back at me so whenever I
go into this girl's house I was sneaking
through the laundry room
they had a door to the outside you go
into the laundry room and come into the
kitchen
well that cat this little gray hitter he
would hide in there they had all these
towels and you know dryer sheets and
stacks of all kind of stuff or whatever
in the laundry room so and it was pitch
black and I couldn't cut the light on
because you're worried you know you
don't want light going out under the
door into the kitchen what if the moms
walking down the hall or whatever you
know I couldn't have the family see that
I was sneaking in so I'd get in that
laundry room and it dude it was like the
laundry was about 9 or 10 feet long to
that from one door to the next door and
it was just a gauntlet bra and every
time like clockwork that little gray
[ __ ] come flying off on one of
the top ropes like Jimmy Superfly Snuka
and just do that four leg drop on me
yeah I mean just and then it was on boy
it was on and you couldn't even see us
it was just
darn wacky fiasco and then you know I'd
make it up to her room and then and then
the cool thing was so then I'd get into
the kitchen finally get away from that
little Mundt you know had a little deal
and I'd then I have to sneak up to her
room and the stairs went over her
parents bedroom so you had to like real
stuff
step on the sides of the stairs that was
a trick don't step out in the middle of
the [ __ ] stairs like somebody that
never broken anybody's housing before
step on the side of them steps you know
so it's really where the wood is strong
and so it doesn't make any sound you get
up to the top and then go sneaking old
girl's bed and we lay in there and dude
that's when you were oh man
that's about when you were young love as
a teenager everything was strong bro
your whole body was just all just caught
up with horror moans you knowing them
hormones were just [ __ ] brought your
eyebrows would just do my eyebrows used
to do laps around my eyes bro you could
see my eyebrow just literally doing
circles around my eyes I was so just
horny you know I would just be so fun
just so funny that my eyebrows would be
dude they'd run off behind my ears dude
do all kind of [ __ ] you know my eyebrows
were run over they've run around did
chasing each other around behind my back
like a couple of squirrels brush
you know squirrels do with different
sides of the tree they'd be like that
man I'd be so horny bro that my eyebrows
would just run right off my [ __ ] face
dude that's how horny I be my eyebrows
would just run right off of my face and
just just like squirrels chasing each
other around my body and I'm laying
there and make out with my girl you know
I mean that's what I did as a teenager
outside of that what do we do mmm and
it's funny I'm have to think about what
happened I don't know it's a great
question I think my brains also just a
little bit fried
today but thank you for taking some of
the backroads and thanks for for calling
him and I do appreciate you being a part
of this past weekend and it's funny as
you're doing that I were acting just for
imagine you driving through my state
thank you guys for checking out this
clip and if you want to see another clip
then you can look at this clip or this
clip either one of these so did you pick
one or he's still just watching me do
this cuz it's alarming